so besides having provisions
that indicate that what is not given to
the federal government can be given to
the local government or the state
government
they were not without substance to say
that it's unconstitutional it is not
you can't find it in any page you can
find
provisions that say that you should have
the right to vote
uh that you should uh be able to vote
regardless of race color or creed
that is in here but not a provision
that suggests that what mr hollins did
was unconstitutional let me thank mr
middoff
all of the intervenors ms bitoff was the
lead but the illegal women voters and
aclu
and individual citizens who took their
time
to come up and indicate our birthright
should not be extinguished today
was a victory for the american people
for those who no matter what their party
affiliation
could walk in dignity because their vote
was counted let's not have any more
foolishness
that continues and this is not going to
stop here because we in the united
states congress
will be looking at these actions in the
aftermath
so that people will not face this kind
of attack on their voting right and
their birthright
thank you very much i'm congressman al
green and i represent the ninth
congressional district in texas
i'm honored to be flanked by my
colleagues and i'm honored to stand here
with um mr hollis uh who is a lawyer
himself
and has done an outstanding job i
believe that this is not about democrats
it's not about republicans
it is about our participatory democracy
and in a participatory democracy the
hallmark
of that participation is the right to
vote
this right to vote is something that we
cherish is something that we have gone
to war over this right to vote
this right to vote is something that we
must protect and i believe that in doing
what has been done
showing that there is no standing for
these parties to bring this litigation
i believe that we now have a ruling that
is constitutional
the standing issue can be raised but it
has already been ruled on
i believe that this participatory
democracy has been opened
it has been expanded and we have now
hundreds of thousands of people
who will vote that might otherwise not
be in the position to do so
this drive through voting is innovative
but it is
also something that is needed and
necessary
it gives people who otherwise might not
come to the polls an opportunity to do
so
so i'm honored to be here to say this to
you that
we cannot allow participation to be
limited
simply because there are those who
choose to think
that they have the ability and the
authority
to decide who votes it's the
constitution that determines who votes
it is it is the right of the people to
exercise this right to vote
and in the future when we find these
kinds of circumstances starting to
manifest themselves
when they start to manifest themselves i
think that we need people with courage
people with courage similar to the
courage that has been exhibited here
today
so that we can take a stand not only for
the people who are immediately impacted
but for unborn generations
who will cherish and protect this right
to vote
i'm honored to acknowledge that my
colleague is here with me
and i'm going to yield to her at this
time
the honorable siva garcia thank you
congressman
my name is sylvia garcia i represent the
congressional district 29 it is a
district
with 77 percent latinos i'm pleased to
be here today with my colleagues
sheila jackson lee and al green and i
see our state senator one of our house
members
you know in the end it's like
the clerk has told us today mr hollins
first of all he's done a magnificent job
of providing access to the polls making
sure it's
easier to vote unlike some of the
republican leadership
and the challengers in this lawsuit who
are about making it harder to vote
drive-through voting is such a
convenience for so many people
but it's also so necessary for many
other people
i went and observed uh the early voting
location in my district in pasadena
in pasadena texas those of you from out
of town i'm not talking california
pasadena texas and
it was busy the entire time it was it is
just so popular
that there was a woman who had come to
vote because she had three children
didn't have daycare so she brought the
three children with her into her suv
there was people there who just didn't
have any other time to vote so that it
was
good for them to be able to do that and
not get out of their cars
i tell people it's it's like you when
you go out to get get something to eat
it's convenient to drive through and get
that mcdonald's
but the food that you get at a
drive-through is the same food
that you get inside the same thing here
mr hollins took great efforts
to have the same safeguards to follow
the same protocol
and the vote is the same outside as it
is
inside but more importantly it's like
congressman green said
it's about our right to vote our right
to vote is sacred
and we must protect it so this is a huge
victory for the 127
000 people who voted to drive throughs
particularly those 14 000 from my
district
so again this is a great day for all of
those voters
and it's a great day for all the voters
of harris county
because i think that drive-through
voting is a keeper
it's one of those things that we decided
to do
during this pandemic but i think it's
something that the public
will demand that it be continued thank
you all very much and i yield to
state senator carol alvarado
so i was not addressed to speak but um
carol alvarado texas state senator
joined here
by my house colleague john rosenthal
look if we have to go this session to
clarify something in the texas
election code we will do so we head to
austin in january
there is no reason we should be here on
the eve
of a very significant election
drive-through voting has been going on
for months and it has been going on in
other places in texas unchallenged
but here we are in harris county
and we know that this has been uh shot
at
to us from a very partisan manner
and so again we stand ready to go back
to austin
and do what we need to do to make sure
that there is never
any question about this type of voting
thank you i'm john rosenthal i'm the
state
representative for house district 135 in
northwest houston
um i could not be more proud to stand
with my colleagues today
i could not be more proud of the work
that chris hollins and our harris county
clerk's office have done to turn around
a situation
where we are in a state where
independent study shows
this is the most difficult state to
register and cast a vote in
and and here now we've gone from worst
in the nation
in in terms of voter participation to
first and our harris county clerk's
office
our county commissioners court and our
county judge have made that happen
if we want to serve the people in order
to represent them
we have to listen to their voice the
people's voices must be heard
and that's all there is to it 127
127 000 voters cast their votes
the decision here today is a righteous
one
i'm i'm beyond words to to
i'm overjoyed that these people's votes
will be counted
their voices will be heard it is the
cornerstone of our democracy that the
people's voice be heard
anyone seeking to diminish that to throw
away
the people's voices to throw away the
votes they are doing the exact
opposite of what democracy is so thank
you very much
i'm really pleased thank you all for
your advocacy
that's it thank you thank you thank you
so much
[Music]
i don't know if anybody cares but i'm
aware of itself
i was a lawyer in the courtroom for 18
plaintiffs that had voted and some
4 000 more that wanted to be there but
i've got one line for you
it is the it is
ironic but the height of arrogance
that steve potsi and his compatriots
would claim that the work chris hollands
has done
to get the turnout going and 127
000 people to vote he claims to be
voter suppression of him
honest god what's in his pleadings he
found otherwise today
yes what is the next step if the other
side
appeals we'll have to look at what they
say in the pill and see whether we fight
him up there
the plaintiffs i was on the side with
with the cap
larry the selka larry tell them how many
well we had 18 that we named but there's
some
4500 people that have wanted to join we
couldn't
do the paperwork to get them all in here
on one day while we're working on the
brief
but they're thousands of people upset
and wanting to make sure that they get
their vote
protected and the judge did that
and the work that chris has done has
done that
thank you
[Music]